a couple of days ago as soon as apple's
spring-loaded event finished
we rushed out a video on the 24-inch
imac talking about the design
specs features and how many of my
predictions ended up being true
but i didn't really have a chance to
share a lot of my honest thoughts and
opinions
and since many of you guys in the
comments seemed to be
very unhappy with the new imac for
multiple different reasons
i figured i'd address some of the
concerns in this video
and give you guys my thoughts on if it's
actually worth
thirteen hundred dollars so let's get
right into it starting with the design
i've seen countless comments with people
disappointed in the new design
calling it ugly mostly due to the white
bezels on the front
and especially the fact that apple kept
the chin around
david from cnn says that it's quote ugly
as sin
richard from techradar says it's badly
designed and then ben from 925 max says
that the design is inexplicable
or basically unexplainable due to the
chin
and of course the white bezels so let me
explain
why apple made those design decisions
and then give you guys my thoughts on
the overall design first off apple's
main goal
was obviously to make it as thin as
possible
basically to blow people's minds and
push the entire computer industry
towards using arm-based chips like their
own apple silicon m1 chip
and to achieve that level of thinness
just 11.5 millimeters
they had to house all of the computer
components including the logic board
the speakers and the fans away from the
display
hence why they kept the chin around but
that's not the only reason
like i mentioned in my previous videos
the imac chin
is iconic and it's instantly
recognizable from across
even a large room but what shocked me
the most was that they got rid of the
apple logo
which to me doesn't really make sense
they could have at least etched an apple
logo into the glass panel
since it also covers the chin which
would have made for a super clean look
like we have on the back of the iphone
12 pro now some people think it's
because of the vasa mount option
that allows you to rotate the display
and use it in vertical mode
but i'm not really sure on top of that
apple of course chose to make the bezels
white instead of black
which is a weird design choice but i
think apple did it for
4 different reasons first the original
imac that had all of the different
colors
also had white bezels and same with the
imac g4
and the imac g5 so they're probably
going for that retro look
second the white bezels give it a sort
of innocent and playful look
along with all the color options which
shows that apple is obviously targeting
the younger non-techie market third the
white bezels make the new imac
instantly stand out compared to any
intel based imac
that's currently out there so if you see
an imac
with white bezels you know it's got
apple silicon
and fourth i think that apple simply
wanted to shock people with the design
making it look as unique as possible
intentionally causing controversy
and leading to many people talking about
it which is basically free marketing
they did it with the airpods which many
people hated at first
but they eventually went viral they did
it with the face id notch on the iphone
10
which people hated but the iphone 10 was
the best selling smartphone in the world
and the new iphone 12 models
are still the best selling in the world
they did it with the triple camera
lenses on the iphone 11 pro
which people called very ugly at first
but they eventually bought it and warmed
up to it
like i said apple likes to shock people
and that's exactly what they're doing
with the 24 inch imac now as for my
personal thoughts
i do think it does look a little bit
weird from the front mainly because they
ditched the apple logo on the huge chin
which i honestly wish was a little bit
thinner
so when we get our 24-inch imac in our
office
next month we're probably gonna stick on
one of those apple stickers
onto the chin to make it look a little
bit better however i think that once
people finally get it into their hands
and actually get to see and feel how
premium
lightweight and thin the design truly is
people are gonna fall in love with it
and the design is gonna quickly grow on
them so in my opinion
from a design and marketing standpoint
apple
absolutely knocked it out of the park
and what i love the most about it
is the super clean flat back the
incredibly good looking stand
and the new magnetic power cable so i've
gotta admit
that the imac is an engineering
masterpiece
now the second thing that people
complained about was the fact that the
imac gets
the same m1 chip that we already have in
the other max
so let me give you four reasons for why
apple gave the 24 inch imac the m1 chip
first off we weren't actually expecting
the m1x chip to be ready yet
since the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros
were reportedly delayed
until the second half of this year so it
would be really weird
to get the m1x and the imac first second
if apple would have given it the m1x
they would have had to greatly raise the
base price and that's a problem because
this
imac with all of its playful colors is
obviously meant for the younger
average consumer market just like the
previous 21.5 inch imac was meant for
and if you think about it the m1 chip is
now being packed into
five different apple products including
the ipad pro
which saves apple a ton of money due to
less r d
and mass manufacturing allowing them to
keep the price of m1 products
low and third the performance of the m1
chip is actually great
it has by far the best web browsing and
common app performance
out of any mac out there even better
than our 15
000 intel base mac pro and since the
imac
is meant for average consumers it's the
best case scenario in that sense
and even for professionals the m1 chip
fares
extremely well against apple's much more
expensive
intel-based macs and tasks like photo
editing in lightroom
video editing in final cut pro music
production
and logic pro and especially xcode
programming
where the m1 is faster than our mac pro
all due to excellent optimization and
alongside
all of that the m1 chip also runs
incredibly cool
silent and it barely uses any power
compared to intel chips
so in terms of performance the m1 chip
is perfect for the 24 inch imac
and the m1x would have honestly just
been overkill for most people
and the same thing goes for people
complaining about having a maximum of 16
gigs of ram
32 would have been overkill for almost
everyone
since apple's unified memory
architecture is incredibly efficient
and in some cases performs much better
than other machines
with the same amount of ram and now
moving on to the fourth reason
the m1 chip is incredibly reliable since
apple is now
controlling the software the machine and
the chip
at the same time so they can optimize
the software
better than ever before this means that
people will no longer have
amd graphics driver issues or have all
of those
intel security chip flaws like spectre
and meltdown
since the m1 chip is super secure just
like apple's iphones
the m1 also allows new great features to
work
like being able to use iphone and ipad
games and apps
having probably the best 1080p webcam
you can get
thanks to the m1 ship's isp the instant
wake feature
which intel max never had and especially
the new touch id magic keyboard which
only works
because of the secure apple silicon chip
so in my opinion
people buying the 24 inch m1 imac today
will be getting an incredibly reliable
and fast system
that'll last for probably 8 to 10 years
without very many issues at all
and that's gonna cause it to hold its
value incredibly well
now moving on to the next thing that
people complained about we have
the ports the base model for thirteen
hundred dollars
only gets two thunderbolt ports and a
headphone jack on the side
compared to the old 21 and a half inch
imac which had two of the same ports
but it added four usb a ports a gigabit
ethernet jack
and an sd card slot this is extremely
disappointing since you're much more
limited
than you previously were and i honestly
believe that apple could have easily
added an sd card slot
on the side if they really wanted to but
they didn't
and what frustrates me the most is that
a recent leak has
basically confirmed that the redesigned
macbook pros coming later this year
will be getting an sd card slot so why
would apple scrap it on the imac
i don't know now if you buy the more
expensive models or if you buy the
upgraded power adapter separately
you do get an ethernet jack built into
the power supply
which i think is absolutely genius
because that's one less cable that you
have to route up to the imac
however the 24 inch imac does not
support
10 gigabit ethernet which is very
disappointing
since you can actually now get it on the
m1 mac mini
but in my honest opinion the 24 inch
imac also supports wi-fi 6
which is actually faster than regular
gigabit ethernet
and these days wi-fi is so reliable that
the average consumer
doesn't even need a wired connection
anymore in fact
all three of our macs that we use
professionally every day in our office
are using wi-fi six even though we could
easily get them connected using ethernet
so i don't think it's that big of a deal
and as far as the limited thunderbolt
port situation
it's not that big of a deal for the
average consumer but it definitely sucks
for tech enthusiasts
because even if you get the more
expensive models you still
only get two thunderbolt ports since the
other two that are added
are only usb-c ports but luckily there
is a perfect solution to this problem
and that's the owc thunderbolt hub which
turns
one thunderbolt port into a usb 3.2 port
and three full speed thunderbolt ports
which we proved to work in our review of
that hub
so definitely check out that video if
you're interested and we're gonna link
it down below
and finally there were a lot of people
that complained about the thirteen
hundred dollar base price
saying that it's way too expensive
considering the fact
that it has the same m1 chip as the 700
mac mini but in my unpopular opinion
it's actually a
killer value for everything that you're
getting just think about it you're
getting a masterpiece of a machine
in terms of the design and the premium
build quality
you're getting a super nice 4.5 k
display
with excellent color accuracy and 500
nits of brightness
and if you didn't already know lg is
selling their ultra fine
24 inch display for 700 alone
and keep in mind that it's only 4k and
not 4.5 k
on top of that you're getting speakers
that apple says are
better than the ones in the imac pro
which i know
are absolutely amazing since i use that
machine
every single day for editing apple also
says that you're getting better
microphones
than on any other mac and you're getting
a 1080p webcam
that's also better than any mac ever
made of course you get the color matched
magic keyboard
and magic mouse included which i can say
for a fact
are the most reliable peripherals that
i've ever used
and yes they do still use lightning to
charge but the batteries
literally last forever so it's not a big
deal at all
and on top of that you're getting the
powerful m1 chip
which has the best web browsing
performance you can get while being
incredibly secure
feature packed and with reliability
that'll last you eight to ten years no
problem
so if you add the value of all of those
things together
the 24-inch imac is a no-brainer for
thirteen hundred dollars
for a lot of average consumers out there
and even for some tech enthusiasts
who want a reliable machine i can tell
you for a fact
that you won't be able to configure a
custom windows desktop pc
or all-in-one that matches these specs
performance accessories and features for
thirteen hundred dollars
there's just no way especially with the
whole chip shortage going on right now
now yes one option is to go with the m1
mac mini
but good luck finding a display in
peripherals this nice
for less than thirteen hundred dollars
total so in my unpopular opinion
apple absolutely knocked it out of the
park with the new 24-inch imac
from the masterpiece of a design and the
m1's performance
to of course the value and the
reliability
and many of the doubters are only gonna
realize it when they actually get it and
see it in person
or read all of the positive reviews that
we're gonna be getting next month
so there you guys go those were my
personal thoughts on the new imac
and if you totally disagree with me go
ahead and comment your thoughts down
below
but if you enjoyed it click that circle
about to subscribe for more videos like
this one
especially our hands-on comparisons with
the imac
definitely check out our ipad pro
thoughts video right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video